welcome to conan o'brien needs a friend
podcast that aims to please it's a nice
slogan and pleases to aim
oh
sometimes you can reverse things and
it's clever no that was one i gave no
thought to beforehand and it means
nothing to say it pleases to aim what
would be our slogan if we had a slogan
uh still making these
uh hope you're hearing them conan
o'brien needs a friend conan o'brien
friends a need it doesn't work
yeah you didn't think about it ahead of
time either that was kind of it's
occurring to me now that very few of
those actually
work and that you have to be clever and
think of them yeah you can't just say
well you know time to take out the trash
and trash out the take no you have to
actually think ahead of time and
and map it out make sure that it lines
up yeah but i can't help it i'm in the
mood to keep trying those without even
thinking about it and hoping that one
magically works out and you know what
one will yeah well eventually one will
and eventually
will will one
nice dammit no that won't i mean almost
no you're almost there no it doesn't
don't don't get mad at me and second of
all i'm trying to be encouraging yeah
but when you encourage someone who just
failed you're being condescending um you
know i just uh tried to take my first
step and feeling you understand
condescending you're being you kind of
unencourage wait hold on a second i'm
trying my best to come up with one of
these we've got to come up with a
legitimate one before this introduction
is over okay but remember let's just put
our best foot forward yeah and remember
forward your best foot oh that doesn't
work either that's not good these are
awful those are bad these are bad yeah
and you know what if you
try and don't succeed eventually you'll
succeed in trying nope
well i mean that one's true but it's
just not poetic it makes sense yeah yeah
what does it sense make oh now you're
just turning into yoda and i'm getting
angry why am i getting angry you realize
yoda
probably said many of these and just
other jedis were around going ah jesus
you know
yeah yoda was probably around just
disappointing people with his lousy fake
aphorisms you know are you comparing
yourself to yoda no i just can picture
him like saying remember when you know
when you add cream to coffee sometimes
coffee you cream
i'll see that one's pretty good and
you're like what
yoda and he's like why's i am and am i
wise and you're like no it's working as
yoda though yeah because people give
yoda so much slack because yoda talks
that way and because he's like just tiny
little creature wrinkly creature and
he's eight thousand years old
he's losing a yoda beef here no no i'm
just saying he gets a lot of slack you
know that yoda shows up at a party and
everyone's like oh my god it's yoda hey
yoda thanks for being here good to be
here it is and is could be
is now here and people like wow
that blew my mind yoda your mind blew
blue eye you
yoda what
no sorry didn't mean oral sex i give
tried to be clever with backwards talk
make mistake not you i'd blow blow are
you
what yoda you gotta go right now there
are kids here
mistake i made sorry b.i
b.i what are you a pirate now yoda
i go now but now i go
what you have to use the bathroom no
leave me do
now i leave
dude oh [ __ ] yoda yoda
yoda what is your problem try to be
clever i do
but back would say hard to make
what
you're having stroke
no i know cause of you to speak
[Laughter]
he's right this uh mri shows he's having
a major occlusion in his brain
he's had a terrible stroke that's
affected his speech center and no one
knew it because they just thought he was
being 2 000 years old clever
hospital take me to hospital now i do
what he's just like dr seuss yoda yeah
one fish two fish red fish blue fish ib
um
yeah i think yoda got a ton of slack and
i think there were many times when yoda
had a few too many drinks and he was
hanging around yeah and everyone was
like wow yoda's saying such cool [ __ ]
but if you think about it the next day
if anyone taped it you know on their
phone yeah they'd be listening it to him
oh my god this is terrible he's not well
yeah or else she went home with him and
this is what he said she went home with
him yeah well i mean he's like picking
up ladies left and right which is like
him he is sexy you are our sexy you
oh wow that's so clever i can't do this
yeah they pick him up and go home with
them no don't do that
we're talking about it he is yeah come
on guys you you kidding women would go
crazy for him they would for yoda oh
yoda what's up well you know what's
going on it's so nice to meet you why is
that my woman voice you know there is a
woman yoda in the phantom menace called
yaddle there is not yeah i swear i said
okay did they do it like is it a thing i
don't know that they're like connected
romantically hold on i'll show you a
picture of her she's hideous looking
well no i'm probably i'm not probably
beautiful but probably beautiful to to
yoda i don't know tell me what you think
when you okay
oh my god
oh my god is that yaddle that's seattle
oh yavi's same species as me supposed to
be attractive she is but horrible
finding her i am maybe they had baby
yoda grogan no no
no
anyway when yoda goes home with girls
are they human women yes this is human
women he's not yaddles no he goes to the
clubs no they aren't yaddles he's not
going home with the oh my god yeah look
at that hair right there post that that
is me in
21 years
look at that hair i'm a yaddle i didn't
want to say anything but she has your
hair she has my hair
yeah so someone at
lucasfilm tried to think of what's the
most hideous look we could go for yeah
and when they got to the hair they just
they took conan hair they did she's got
the pompadour and everything she really
the same color the same type of hair
it's all
identical sexy you are yeah though cause
conan hair you grew
he likes you he's a fan of yours he's
turned on by my hair face hideous it is
but hair makes me horny it is yeah it'll
wear that wig to look like conan
[Music]
one request yeah will i have
conan wig you wear then we do
okay
i'm sorry yoda gets so much slack
he's such an [ __ ] um